fresh prince is back and more dramatic
and grittier than ever but at least we
got a hot uncle fail guys no
meet the new bel air crew in daddy phil
y'all
[Music]
now this is a story all about how my
life got flipped turned upside down
jabari banks is the new will smith said
they're gonna roll out the red carpet
for you
congratulations to you you have the role
of will on bel-air
i got on the call
and there will was and i was like wait i
was just so confused i'm stuck you know
and cause will's been such a hero to me
and such a teacher throughout my whole
life so that was such a beautiful
beautiful experience i'll never ever
forget that the drama gets into why will
left philly
welcome good to see you for his super
rich fam out west and i'd like to take a
minute just sit right here
that's the new aunt viv and uncle phil
and they both get it new uncle phil
looks nothing like original uncle phil i
hit the gym i push a little iron every
now and then look that's one reason why
he thought he was gonna get this roll
cause he was like i thought they were
gonna follow the pattern of the original
show when we did our chemistry test and
i saw him in the room with the chemistry
i was like i was almost offended i was
like
and then as soon as adrian started
speaking the whole vibe and swag that is
just adrian in this character just felt
like truth i need you to say it will the
bank's kids are also back there's ashley
social media influencer hillary and
carlton who's no longer the nerdy cousin
in
west philadelphia born and raised on the
playground is where i spend most of my
days i hope uh one day we can talk about
why you're really here will smith he's
he's executive producing the show and he
is just uh
he's given us so much love and support i
remember the first day of that camera
test the show runners they were like you
know the smith family wants you to know
this about to be just the craziest
experience of your life um so use us as
a resource and so the smith family has
they've just been really really lovely
throughout the whole process and don't
forget about will's bff jazz i looked at
my kingdom i was finally there just to
sit on my throne as the prince
of
them
[Applause]
i can't wait for this
i'm
to be so excited
god bless you oh no that uncle feels
fine i'm good with that yeah i'm really
trying to set up this monday alibi
the first three episodes of bel air
premieres sunday on peacock scan that qr
code to get signed up for more daily pop
check out this playlist here and how
fresh is the new cast of bel air weigh
in in the comments below plus hit that
subscribe button so you never miss a
thing